can you explain why did Obama kill his
Chef yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
first of all first of all day or no can
we have this conversation
can we have this conversation this is
the conspiracy is going around so here's
the thing with this with this tragic
incident that happened on Martha's
Vineyard yeah okay
also can I just say one thing real
quickly
when I was in the south of France there
was this beautiful Vineyard I wanted to
take a jog by so I asked the concierge
at the hotel and I was like hey man
there's a Vineyard around here can I go
take a run by it which direction would I
go and the guy goes oh in in English he
goes he goes oh yes there is a vine yard
over there you can go take a run by and
I was like oh [__]
Vineyard
is just a fine yard which in American
English gross is disgusting I have a
Vineyard on my property I have a vine
yard on my property there's there's a
yard of vines on my property isn't it
crazy great marketing unbelievable
marketing yeah just franchising anything
can make it so much do you know what I
mean thank God there's no like grape
yards in the [__] South because
Southerners would ruin that they would
come on yard yeah they call Vineyards I
got a great Chardonnay in my Vineyard
yeah that's Chardonnay actually and
they'd be very proud of it too they
would yeah they love mispronouncing
things oh God like Mobile Alabama is
mobile
which one is right it's m-o-b-i-l-e I'm
pretty sure but which is mobile like you
have a mobile phone but they call it
mobile because they just love
mispronouncing things yeah Italy Texas I
got friends whose family there Italy
Texas they like really take pride in
doing things poorly I love that yeah
that's not actually kind of nice about
it thank you in the last two I was like
yeah Italy is way more fun at least
you'll actually be hard to say to me if
you say Italy they're like no no that's
over there you also got to create some
separation like there's enough
separation no I don't think anyone's
gonna show up to Italy Texas be like oh
no I thought oh [__] I was wondering if
the flight was so cheap dude what a
mistake okay
Obama's cook
dies on a paddle board and
March 100 feet away from the shore eight
feet deep water the guy can swim he can
swim there's videos of him swimming
he's I assume paddle boarded before you
know go out on a paddle board 100 feet
out if you don't know how to swim it's
kind of a dangerous thing to do
um there was a person that was like I
don't know 100 feet away that said they
saw it happen and couldn't get to them
yeah apparently I heard that I don't
know in time no one knows who like that
second person is apparently
I think I think this is the Maxine bro
if I'm being honest with you yeah let's
go I think that I think that he has some
heart issue like a lot of us have
developed heart issues from the Maxine
and I think he got double dose and I
think he got the boosters and I think
that Maxine kicked in right when he was
on that paddle board can I give up can I
give you a Counterpoint blaming the
Maxine go he is black
what does that mean probably
unmaccinated oh he is around Obama and
he's going to public events Obama's to
be vaccinated Obama one dose Max
yeah I mean half yeah I don't even think
the white half him was like we'll do it
the black half was like I don't trust it
bro you think so single dose I've been
money Obama single day ain't no way bro
ain't no way he can see him being at
home yeah I don't trust the government
I could see it yeah I couldn't see it
but it is a possibility the only way I
could see him dying on the paddleboard
the only way is if he had some sort of
cardiac arrest
something like that or a stroke there's
no way I could see him yeah drowning
yeah they haven't reported on that I
just can't see him falling off and
drowning I don't see that as a realistic
option even if you couldn't swim at all
I don't know why you'd be on the paddle
board without some sort of like leash
maybe you don't have a leash at all I
think if you can't swim at all you're
not going a hundred feet [__] out
right two well he can't swim if you've
seen the video you sent I saw it yeah
that's what I'm saying like so he can
swim you can get back to the board
or you can get back to shore
because we know you can swim so the only
you seem skeptical of that no I'm I'm
trying to find I'm trying to find a
Counterpoint what you're saying so I
guess what I'm saying is if you
experience some sort of cardiac
situation or a stroke situation that
limited your ability to swim and save
yourself that makes sense but why aren't
they reporting on that I mean I don't
know if they've done the autopsy I'm
assuming it has to be something at least
to the autopsy I know that there's no
foul play I know they're still waiting
on toxicology which if there was vowel
play I think toxicology would reveal
yeah yeah that's what I'm thinking like
what do you think toxicology is going to
show two dates with Maxine possibly two
extra booster situations
or some [__] right you're out in the sun
all day you get heat stroke boom I mean
if there's a capacity a type of person
that's more built to handle that that
you know I think he's got it I think
it's him yeah it's not like an Irishman
that's paddle boarding that's true yeah
I don't think it has to do with melanin
I think heatstroke could just get
anybody any time
I don't know if that's if I don't know
about that I'm serious it's Gotta Be
heat you think black people are better
at songs
is that true no
I think back there are better at
handling Heat
why is it possible
I think the body handles the Heat and
the direct sun better yeah 100 I can't
handle Heat
why not like I'm always up that's why
this room is always free whiteness oh it
could be a past life maybe this guy's a
past life White
yes yes you have that you have but
nobody's gonna talk about the the Spy
submarines talk to me maybe it was an
Asian spy submarine I took them out holy
[__] he went out a little bit too far
got a little too close
damn nobody talking about that come on
bro I mean it's just such an odd thing
unless you just like falling and hit his
head or something
the paddle board no come on he's also
how old is he he could be a free guy you
slip and the paddle just happens to like
you fall paddle hits you or the board
maybe hits you for whatever reason
knocks you out then you drown because
you're knocked out yeah Devil's Advocate
also you almost drowned am I making a
joke in surfing and what didn't seem
like it made it but you did just come
out so a conspiracy theories would be
like oh he just came out with his
Netflix special he's going at everybody
going at all the fire authorities I bet
there was some foul play because that
guy can surf why would he die on a
surfboard he's a trained Surfer my thing
would like drowning if I'm a powerful
person I'm trying to take someone out
I'm gonna go with what is the most
common way that people die
right like just poison them or something
and be like oh he's got oh yeah he had
toxicology would show he got poison bro
if you're the if you're a former if
we're saying the conspiracies that like
people within the elites Obama kill this
guy I'm like just do the thing that's
the most obvious and then she the dogs
College yeah like I don't think it was
Obama that did it
what do you think
uh somebody
nah but people dying out actually
sounds good it was somebody that's a way
to take people out though it was
somebody yeah it was [__] somebody
did it dude a guy
probably
probably guy maybe this is a guy who
lived on Martha's Vineyard and he was
like black people are moving in let's
cut this [__] out that's the Black
Island though oh that's a Black Island
the Black Island but there is a larger
percentage of very wealthy black people
that go vacation there Illuminati blacks
and when did that start do you know
about that someone told me about this
recently can't talk about that oh my bad
sorry
I almost tricked you into town
boy okay but think about let's say
you're one of the most powerful people
in the world you're trying to take out
someone that knows something someone
that's close to you yeah how do you take
them out
definitely paddable right like if
someone dies drowning you're always be
like oh that's so weird who dies
drowning right that's that's a pretty
uncommon way to die yeah right or not
it's gonna create more suspicion you're
saying yeah I'm like yeah poison him
yeah a car accident is more common than
drowning this is your argument for why
there probably is no foul play correct
because if you wanted to take someone
out you would do it in a conspicuous I
believe that powerful people are killing
people all the time no question yeah
American Elites Russian Elites whatever
people are dying and I think it's
happening in more subtle ways that don't
even come on the radar how nice is it to
be Russian where like if you don't like
someone and you're wealthy you can just
kill them and then everybody will look
the other way yeah it's just accepted
and you don't have to go through this
whole like sneak in the poison this
would be the word so yeah if you're rich
it's nice convenient convenient okay
like because in America like you have to
sneak the poison in like cheesecake and
then you're like watch him eat it and
maybe he doesn't take that bite and
you're just like [__] he's like I'm
trying to watch my figure and you're
like [__] don't yeah anything yeah
there's ever a night to cheat tonight is
the [__] night yeah it's a stressful
situation trying to murder somebody that
you don't like you talking from
experiencing I've never tried to murder
somebody I mean
have you thought about it no I don't
know no I'm trying to think if there's
ever a situation where I was like oh it
could be so much easier
there was never a couple flight
stewardess that you wanted to take no
never murder oh never never crushed your
mind never never back there one time
you're like oh I wish it just a light
would fall somebody interview you on a
white cast Maybe
that never happened
no no that never happened okay
interesting yeah I want them to live and
Thrive but yeah if you're a powerful
person how do you take someone out I
think you go the most obvious route you
got to do a heart attack while they're
sleeping sorry what if they were trying
to poison Obama in food and then he
taste tested the food and then bang now
we're talking that's [__] good now
we're talking that's [__] good wow it
was maybe a hit on Obama holy takes a
little bit off didn't think much of it
holy [__]
I think we cracked the code I think
we're gonna be it right there because
Obama what are you you're out of office
he's too cool to get poisoned you'll see
your color mommy
they don't want her to run for a present
oh [__] oh that's a big threat and maybe
this is a
maybe this is a message hey if you're
even thinking of running for president
we just want to let you know we could
get to you yeah we're going to take this
person out who's close to you so we can
get them we can get you [__] everyone
pointed out this photo and they're like
this happened like a couple days after
the chef passed away oh yeah oh that's
what that was he was so funny his
fingers are broken he's got a black guy
I was like you think he did it himself
like there's no like you can't really
think Obama killed a guy with his own
hands yeah he's what 55 at this point
yeah I'm like even if you're like the
most hardcore conspiracy there is
how many days
do you go golfing
like you can't golf that day but tea
times are so hard to get that's what I'm
saying yeah but not if you're not in the
present but so I'm just like what is the
amount like
he only missed one meal
my man missed one dinner and he's like I
gotta hit the links bro we gotta work
this out yeah yo that is
that is this is your chef from when you
were in the White House you've known
this guy for how long now but this still
sucks it's a guy who died so no no it's
horrible it's horrible what I'm trying
to say is he went and played golf very
soon after two days afternoon that's a
little crazy I think you've got it at
least everyone Grieves different
wear black
he didn't even wear black yeah he had
white shorts on
songs
that's right but isn't wearing black uh
a golf like
you're not supposed to do that or is
that just tennis I don't know he is he's
the 44th President of the United States
of America he can wear whatever he wants
on a golf course
he shouldn't be golfing bro yeah and if
you do go golfing make sure nobody's
taking pictures of you yeah shut the
whole course down to something you can't
be out there having a good time yeah
it's a little crazy is it almost like
you're an older guy he knows so many
people a lot of people he knows probably
die it's his Chef how close of a
relationship is that I don't know the
closest I've never had a chef I don't
know how close that that you're with
them three times a day how many people
do you think Obama has directly
encountering three times a day was it
his only chef
this is private Chef so probably his
it's his guy and the house can be super
big they might just call him once the
food is ready like then they're boys
boys but like you are interacting and
they're curating your food they're like
part of your life they're traveling with
you at the very least he's an employee
that has been with you for 15 years
since oh wait 2023 now at the very least
this is an employee that's been with me
for 15 years that's a long time two days
you can golf after two days bro I say
you give it a week
maybe I just don't get golf yeah that's
the thing you don't call for nothing
this is the best endorsement for golf
it's like how fire is this sport there
like this you can't stay away yeah dude
can't stay away oh [__] he was golfing
maybe it was a Saudis oh
oh wait how they run golf now Run Golf
um
I don't know I was trying to go with
them but I don't really care